this is the new hot air nozzle for
stoking the fire some 1000 construction
workers are overhauling this blast
furnace during its turnaround production
engineer rhinock Locke is hoping it'll
go back on stream in a few days every
day counts as revamping it costs 200
million euros
as it have done so old bird under I'm
not we're upgrading everything around
the furnace to during normal operations
you can't get in here to do repair work
a la MIT Modena zeod the blast furnace
was in continual operation for 20 years
this turnaround was a scheduled event
only Heine clock and his colleague are
permitted to crawl through the last open
ventilation shaft they film it with a
small camera our cameraman has to stay
outside the shaft is too dangerous
listen this is Europe's biggest blast
furnace its internal volume is 50 500
cubic meters yangu structures inside
diameter is 14 meters 90 and that
translates into a furnace that can
produce up to 12,000 tons of pig iron a
day we have to do the masonry work by
hand because everything has to fit
exactly we have to keep the joints tight
and it all has to be properly sealed so
that the heat doesn't penetrate to the
furnace Shell's editing karna clock is
used to the mist when it rains the water
evaporates immediately and the 100 meter
high blast furnaces arse waved in fog
four of these blast furnaces rise into
the sky here at the tussin Hope Factory
in the Ruhr Valley they produce pig iron
which is remelted and processed into
steel as production engineer China clock
has to ensure that the three furnaces
still on stream continue to work as
usual yeah mine up we keep tapping the
iron and filling a torpedo little stain
Ian depending on how fast we tap the
iron filling the ladle can take half an
hour or even an entire hour this is an
item soon
tapping from the blast furnace involves
molten pig iron at a temperature of 1400
70 degrees Celsius
if the quality of the pig iron is up to
standard China clock has the furnace
continue operating as it is
as on saunas good boy 12,000 workers
produce more steel at this site than
anywhere else in Europe Eva means you
own other dimensions here are immense
but it all runs efficiently anyway they
may be - a most fascinating part well a
normal working day is pretty fascinating
fagor here in production no one day is
quite like another capping the iron is
one of the most fascinating sights I
member watching it when I came here with
my grandfather he worked here and now I
work here
oh and get see you know 9 o'clock
studied metallurgy like many of his
colleagues in the control room he comes
from a metalworker family he was no Judy
Heumann query in constant contact with
the staff outside they let us know if
there are any problems but as you see we
have lots of electronics here and it's a
very modern control room with Nvidia the
gigantic furnaces are charged with two
materials the red iron ore melts to
become molten pig iron in Chima is that
the diagram shows the filling profile
spots it's black is the coke and the red
is the flux
what if they hire Noren had attached or
did something
at the end of the shift China clock has
to climb 40 meters to return to the
construction workers they've just
finished work on the connections for the
coolant water they work around the clock
and shifts the turnaround is on a very
tight schedule and soon the blast
furnace must be ready to go back into
production